DANIEL SIEBERG: Hi there.
I'm Daniel Sieberg on
day two of I/O Live.
And we are in the Chrome
showcase, joined right now by
NJ from Adobe to talk about a
couple of really cool projects
that you've been working on,
Shadow and Brackets.
Which one do you want to
start with, by the way?
NJ JARAMILLIO: Let's start
with Brackets.
So Brackets is a free and
open-source code editor for
front-end web development.
So it's built in HTML, CSS, and
JavaScript, and it's for
editing HTML and CSS
and JavaScript.
So if you're the kind of person
who can use Brackets,
you do front-end web development
all day, you can
actually contribute to and
extend Brackets because it's
an open source project.
So I'm going to go ahead
and launch it here.
And you can see that although
it's built-in HTML, we're
currently packaging it as a
desktop application, mainly so
that you can edit the files
on your local hard drive.
And we're actually using
a Chromium-based shell.
So that's one of the ways that
we're using Google technology
to help with the project.
So you can see that this
is actually the
Bracket source code.
By default, Brackets opens
editing it's own source code--
it's kind of this conception
thing.
And you can see that it's got
the standard color coding and
other things that you would
want in a text editor.
Now, it's not totally ready
for prime time yet.
We've only been working on
it for a few months.
But because it's open source,
we're hoping that the
community can jump in and
help make it better.
And a couple of the ideas that
we're seeding, that we think
are a little bit innovative
about this, that you might not
find in a more generic text
editor, are focused on
front-end web development.
So for example we have this
idea of quick editing.
So here I've got a tag for Body,
and let's say I want to
tweak the styles for that.
I can just hit a Quick Edit
key, and we find the rules
that are relevant to that tag.
And then we just bring them
right in to here.
You can tweak them quickly,
and then just dismiss the
editor really quickly.
So you don't have to jump around
between files a lot.
Or if I've got a tag that has
a bunch of rules applied, I
can browse between them.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Very cool.
So it's all about making life
a little easier and more
efficient when you're
working with code.
NJ JARAMILLIO: Exactly.
And then on top of that, we
have this idea of live
development.
Again here, we're leveraging
the Chrome Developer tools.
Now, normally when you use the
Chrome Developer tools or
other kinds of in-browser tools,
you're kind of poking
at stuff in the browser, and
you're copying and pasting
what you want to do back
into your code.
But here we've actually enabled
it directly from your
code editor.
So if I'm here in my real code,
this is my actual source
code, and I go and I start
typing, you can see it updates
the color--
DANIEL SIEBERG: It's reflected
in the browser [INAUDIBLE].
NJ JARAMILLIO: Exactly,
exactly.
Or If I want tweak the margin
between these guys here, oh,
they're a little too tight,
I start typing
a new margin value.
And as I'm typing I can see,
oh, that's too big, oh,
that'll work nicely-- so
I have this really live
development experience.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's
really cool.
All right, let's move on to
Shadow then and see what
that's all about.
NJ JARAMILLIO: OK,
that's great.
So Shadow is really aimed at,
again, speeding the workflow
of mobile web development.
So a problem I have a lot is
I'm working on a mobile
website, and then I have to go
to all my different devices
and check out what I did, and I
have to go and refresh, and
all this all this
kind of stuff.
DANIEL SIEBERG: See how it
looks, of course, which is
very important.
NJ JARAMILLIO: Exactly.
Shadow makes it really
easy to just do it
all from your desktop.
So I've got this little
shadow extension.
Again, it's built as
a Chrome extension.
And you can see that I've got
all my devices connected here.
So now let me go to a website
like the Boston Globe website,
which is well known
for being a good,
responsive design website.
And I go there.
And you see, as soon as I go
here it starts to refresh on
all my devices.
I don't have to touch
them at all.
DANIEL SIEBERG: I don't know
if folks can see that here,
but it is on all of
these devices.
It happened almost
simultaneously.
NJ JARAMILLIO: Exactly.
So I've got my iPad, I've got
my brand-new Nexus 7 here--
plug--
and all that stuff.
And you can see that as I
navigate around, it's
following what I'm doing.
So it's literally shadowing what
I'm doing, which is where
the name comes from.
And so this is available as a
free download right now, as a
preview release on Adobe
Labs at labs.adobe.com.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Very cool.
And so, any learnings that you
want to pass on to other
developers as you work on
both of these projects?
NJ JARAMILLIO: Well one of
things, especially for
Brackets, is we found that some
people say things like,
is JavaScript a robust enough
language for doing this kind
of web development?
And we found that actually, you
can build a high-quality
performant text editor with file
access and all this kind
of stuff, built directly in
JavaScript and CSS and HTML.
And we've learned a lot by doing
this project, and we
also want to hear from people
who are much more experienced
developers than us.
Take a look at our
source code.
We're on GitHub,
github.com/adobe/brackets.
You can come, fork the code,
make a pull request, build
extensions.
We really want the community to
contribute their own ideas
to it, because we think it's
really going to be a great
platform for text editors for
web development in the future.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right.
I love that collaborative
effort.
NJ, thank you so much.
We appreiate it.
NJ JARAMILLIO: All right.
Thanks very much.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
We turn now to the
guys at Autodesk.
And I'm sorry, Randy, I forgot
to bring my 3D glasses.
Is that going to be all right?
Can we still check
this stuff out?
RANDY YOUNG: Yeah, we have
things in reality here, so
you'll be fine.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right.
Well, so we're talking about the
ability to share and view
files from a desktop
to the cloud.
Walk me through what
you've got.
RANDY YOUNG: OK.
So I'm here to talk about
Autodesk 360, which is our
cloud offering to enable
our desktops to share
over mobile and web.
And so what we did here for
Google I/O is we connected
into Google Drive through a
Chrome map, to display large
files in the web browser.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And so some of
these are 3D objects that
normally would be very
difficult, if not
impossible to view?
RANDY YOUNG: Yeah.
So without the desktop apps,
just until recently, you
wouldn't be able to share
these files at
all over the web.
So we actually created this
WebGL plug-in that will allow
you to view large-format files
on the web browser.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right.
Let's have a look.
RANDY YOUNG: OK.
So what we did was you
can get in through
adding the app to Chrome.
And then through Google Drive
you can actually share files
with people that don't actually
have the desktop app.
And through the plug-in they
can see these large models,
and even click on objects and
highlight and get metadata
inside of the objects.
So it's really enabling people
to see their designs and share
their designs with people that
don't necessarily have the
desktop apps.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's
fantastic.
Great.
Anything else you want to
mention real quick?
RANDY YOUNG: Just go visit
us on 360.autodesk.com.
DANIEL SIEBERG:
360.autodesk.com.
All right.
Randy, thank you so much.
We're going to move on now and
talk to Michael, who's got a
demo for us here involving the
ability to capture objects
using a camera on a different
device, and then get this
mesh, and finally print it
out through a 3D printer.
Walk us through this.
MICHAEL BEALE: That's right.
We've got a video playing
in the background here.
And it's an example of Chris
here, taking photographs of a
flower that he's seen
in the market.
And he's reconstructing a 3D
mesh from all the different
camera angles.
It's a product we've
given to the
community called 123D Catch--
something that you can get on
our website if you go to
123Dapp.com.
Once you've taken those photos
and you've reconstructed the
mesh, you can print them out
through cardboard cutouts.
So if you've got some paper and
scissors you can cut out
these little templates,
use a Chromebook.
It's a WebGL app, so it's
accessible by lots of
different browsers, et cetera.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And you've been
working with the folks at
MakerBot, I see.
MICHAEL BEALE: Right.
The tech shop guys, with
their laser cutters.
We tried out some
of these ideas.
And we've cut out, here, a
Tyrannosaurus Rex with
cardboard using some
laser cutters.
Using that same 3D
mesh, we can also
send it to a 3D printer.
So this is one of the MakerBot
3D printers.
And we've been demonstrating
here at Google I/O how we can
print out something
like a little
owl made of PVC plastic.
It takes about half an hour
to print one of these out.
But it demonstrates for the
consumer market that they can
get something from taking a
photograph and bring it all
the way to something that they
can prototype very quickly.
DANIEL SIEBERG: A
tangible object.
MICHAEL BEALE: Yeah.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's
amazing.
All right, any lessons you want
to pass along as you went
through this project?
MICHAEL BEALE: I think if I
could probably give something
back to the developer community,
I'd say, keep
pushing for WebGL and
the open standards.
We're trying to move all of
our desktop things to give
them reach.
So WebGL's a great standard
to push forward.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Extremely
powerful.
We'd love to see wider adoption
of it, of course.
MICHAEL BEALE: That's it.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right.
Well, are you going to play with
your models here as we
say goodbye?
Is there anything else?
MICHAEL BEALE: We'll probably
print a few more out for you.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Print
a few more out?
OK, cool.
Michael, thank you so much.
We appreciate it.
MICHAEL BEALE: Pleasure.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right.
For this segment I feel like I
should be doing a cartwheel in
or something more dramatic.
We're talking about Cirque du
Soleil and we're joined by
Chris from Subatomic
Systems and Justin
from Cirque du Soleil.
I'm really excited to see this
demo, so maybe Chris, can you
talk me through what
was involved with
putting this together?
CHRIS WEBB: Sure.
So Movi.Kanti.Revo is an
interactive journey that takes
the user through an imaginary
world of beauty and awe and
wonder, and is designed
primarily to engage the
person's imagination and
evoke their emotions.
And it utilized the latest
web technologies that are
supported by Google
Chrome to do this.
So the experience itself,
which we have here, is a
preview for Google I/O. And the
full version of this will
launch in September.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Now I'm going to
get you to walk us through
the demo while Justin, you talk
us through the narrative
of what's going on here with
the Cirque du Soleil theme.
So can you go ahead and
walk us through?
CHRIS WEBB: Sure thing.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So Justin, go
ahead and describe what we're
seeing here.
JUSTIN GILBERT: So we started
with the experiment.
So we see the immersive world.
And actually you see the girl.
DANIEL SIEBERG: What
is she doing here?
CHRIS WEBB: This is our guide.
And here at the intro, at this
stage she's showing the user
how to interact, to navigate
through the experience.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Because
obviously there's no menu that
comes up or anything
like that.
CHRIS WEBB: No, there's
no menu that comes up.
DANIEL SIEBERG: But you can
interact with it in ways that
you wouldn't expect,
necessarily.
CHRIS WEBB: Correct.
Yeah.
This interactive experience
utilizes getUserMedia to
recognize the user's face and
then detects movement of the
user to actually navigate
through the experience.
So there, the guide is
showing us if we lean
left, it moves left.
If we lean right,
it moves right.
If we look up, down, the camera
moves accordingly.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Now can you walk
us through some more of
the sequences here?
CHRIS WEBB: Sure.
She's about to come back.
OK.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Oh,
I hear her coming.
And what's the overall goal with
this, Justin, in terms of
the user experience and getting
into that Cirque du
Soleil world-- which people know
maybe from watching one
of the performances, but online,
what's the hope in
terms of terms of
user experience?
JUSTIN GILBERT: Yeah.
Basically when you see a show
we put people on the edge of
their seat because
we want people to
connect to their emotion.
And what we want to achieve with
this kind of application
is just to reproduce this in
the interactive space.
DANIEL SIEBERG: There
she is again.
OK, so what's she doing here?
CHRIS WEBB: This is one setting
in the journey.
Again this is a preview, so
we're getting an abbreviated
experience.
And then the full experience
that comes out in September
will be a beginning to end
journey that takes us through
a number of settings within
this imaginary world.
And here, our guide is about
to take the leap of faith,
which will take us to
the next setting.
And as a user, you actually
follow her as
she takes the leap.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And you can
control some elements of her
experience as she's going
through this?
CHRIS WEBB: Yeah.
In fact, I'll use a keyboard
here for the demo purpose to
show you how the user, if they
move left or right, can
control the world--
DANIEL SIEBERG: Wow.
CHRIS WEBB: --and actually
move through it.
So you're literally traveling
through the world based on
your movements.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Wow.
That's awesome.
Well, Justin from Cirque du
Soleil, and Chris from
Subatomic Systems, I know
you guys have worked
really hard on this.
And I think that a lot of folks
are going to be excited
to try it out.
Thank you so much for giving
us a little preview.
I'm going to cartwheel
out of here and move
on to the next one.
Thanks, guys.
JUSTIN GILBERT: You're
welcome.
CHRIS WEBB: Sure thing.